I want to talk about a statistic that I
read just yesterday that blew my mind
check this out 10,000 baby boomers a day
retire Wow every day 10,000 baby boomers
retired just a top work they quit their
jobs they leave the workforce a huge
number of them and they still have many
years ahead of them probably not a lot
to do yeah you know what I mean
seriously it's it's it's gonna be a
national epidemic of baby boomers around
probably killing time so I thought we'd
check in in a new segment we call
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was horrifying he's making the most
of it yeah let's check out another one
[Music]
okay that's one less we have to worry
about instead what's that one more
[Music]
now I'ma pass the mic to my lovely wife
she's a fly
MC and the light of my life so the bus
the rhyme without further ado take it
away Mary Sue Jesus Christ
[Music]
let's get out of this country now we're
going to Iceland how oh I disagree
there's nothing white people can't do
good one Andy hey thanks for watching be
sure to click Subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography